bonsoir à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et cette émission je voudrais la dédier
à toutes les femmes qui nous regardent
donne moi ton coeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sais-tu de trouver une chanson avec nos
femmes femmes femmes
simplement je dis ça mais je le reste
est dans mon coeur
fairy tale et j'aimerais qu'on fasse un
truc
j'aurais convoi qui valent plus vite
entre delhi vv et hubert reeves je vais
demander à kelly de commander vous avez
commandé un big mac
mathieu qu'elle va commencer il va
commander un filet o fish 6 et le
livreur de kelly qui arrive en premier
ouais tout son côté du public aura droit
à son menu corps de mathieu ciel tandis
que mathieu qui mangera gratuitement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le côté du public de kenny ghana venue
du mac
laurent basique est arrêté
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'on m'a dit je vais préparer des
définitions sur le chroniqueur
aujourd'hui on doit trouver de qui il
s'agit je voudrais aller présenter grâce
à des définitions vas-y vas-y mais il
faut pas de vie n'est pas ce que je dis
le nombre eric naulleau la définition
c'est bon gars qui nous explique le bon
goût certain jean michel maire toujours
en ballotage 3 10e quand mes couilles
elie blonde platine qui aiment les
reflets auburn
à l'époque j'avais pas les couilles des
fallait simplement parce qu'on m'a dit
que ça faisait très très mal donc je
regardais sur internet les recettes de
grand mère
on a fait les aime tenir bon il est je
vois un article qui explique qu' il ya
un truc qui fait repousser les cheveux
c'est c'est le sperme c'est exactement
donc je m'enferme dans d'enfin je me
réfugie dans la salle de bain je te moi
ça me caresser un peu et quand je
recueille un peu de masse immense je me
létale sur le crâne et ma femme rentre
au pire des moments elle m'a dit mais
chéri mais qu'est ce que tu fais et moi
très jeune et jolie bague coutts par
rapport à laquelle vit si j'ai des
implants donc j'ai regardé un truc il
paraîtrait que le sperme pour la
repousser les cheveux le mieux mon amour
ça fait 30 ans qu'on est ensemble
est ce que j'ai de la moustache
aujourd'hui 10 mars est une journée très
importante pour moi c'est l'anniversaire
de quelqu'un que je chie laissait deux
chèques north east
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gc
mais c'est rien pour lui
[Musique]
avec moi vous à le faire
[Applaudissements]
mais ce soir on a la santé n'est pas mon
honneur de recevoir mike horn avec nous
j'ai dit des fois j'ai dit qui est des
relais messieurs jeudi m'énerve c'est
relou il a tout le prix celui-là il n'a
rien décision il est bon et les beaux
gosses et d'aventuriers il peut te faire
des merguez avec de ddd silex mon frère
tu l'as tu le mets dans le désert mon
frère et puis du couscous avec du sable
et tu y penses tu te retrouves avec
jules à au club med pas sexy est mort
c'est bon car l'immeuble
elle arrive tir à l'arc bin dans le
mille îles à amélie des demandes des
sports dessus c'est à dire toutes les
maps et toutes les maple bonne paye son
cobaye corps derrière toi tu dois
attendre la troisième semaine quand ils
s'embarquent toi tu cherches un
aventurier tu cherches ou pas du tout je
pense que cherchent ils opposaient de
mon père c'est vrai cette les modèles
montrent trois marchés car il en
hypoglycémie les panneaux va présider à
toi je veux dire ici qu'il est le
meilleur aventurier à l'atelier 12 août
ces castes alba oui bah oui je me suis
même dit est-ce qu'il a des yeux fermés
il voit pas le danger est ce que tu te
sens de refaire une autre une nouvelle
émission de télé ou pas
marc faire des trucs ou pas ouais je
pense que monsieur baba si tu me faire
confiance je te fais quoi moi je te fais
confiance
par contre toi de me faire part confiant
[Applaudissements]
ce à quoi moitié ce que j'aimerais où
nous la chute d'un hélicoptère on sait
pas où on est et on se débrouille ouais
je veux qu'on fasse ça oui ça c'est
facile
ouais ça c'est non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après l'erreur n'a rien rien on n'a pas
d'argent on a pas on n'a même pas et un
pic à rien on n'a rien on va tous les
deux et on sait pas on joue la femme ça
et vous les gens quand ils disent que
vous j'ai peur des perdu tout ça mais
moi je sais que je vive sur la terre je
suis perdue sur la terre c'est l'astuce
change de planète est pas perdu
exactement que tu nous fait don de vous
dites la vérité vous et isabelle alors
ma part ou alors l ai fait un truc soit
un transfert à chaque fois que vous la
voyez pas parce que quand ya pas la
caméra sur l ennemi c wad ici comme ça
dans l'oreille mon frère et elle va
chercher mais je sais pas ce qu'il ya si
on m'a dit il ya le collier d'immunité
elles sortent des trucs là mais sans
déconner laddh à la fois à la sortie ni
entier savait que ça fait jouir de
mettre le stylo dans l'oreille ah oui ça
réjouir 1,5 kg contamin des petites
statuettes avec mes crottes de nez aux
veaux crottes de nez koh lanta et après
je les jette et plus elles font gruger
content non satisfaction d'avessac c'est
pas vrai as tu des marche pas chez elle
à flinguer à la flânerie à mesaieed à
sortir dans la rue demain c'est là bas
qu'il fait des statuts et avec ses
crottes de z qui a déjà été dans une
boîte échangiste à quelle heure ces six
mois la sofico suffit ma faim les
crottes de nez dans l'antre de la déco
suis allé j'ai été invité une fois pour
toi
cet été pour un concert à dans une boîte
échangiste et bien sûr invités pour un
concert curiosité en fait voilà ce que
disent tout et j'en ai et vous êtes vous
étonné il se passait des choses
ouais c'était non mais je peux même pas
vous raconter tellement c'était mais est
ce que toi tu as fait des choses non moi
j'ai rien fait mais en fait les amis qui
m'avait proposé de venir était en train
de faire des trucs mais il me parlait
comme si c'était normal je les reconnais
ce qu'elle avait les chaussures comme ça
en l'air elle était encore bien ça va
mieux taux réels motifs géants fait bon
voilà et donc je me suis assise à côté
d'elle elle n'a parlé comme si de rien
n'était j'y allais dans le temps mais je
trouvais ça marrant c'est est nouveau
mais maintenant c'est d'une banalité son
nom puis c'est toujours la même chose en
fait c'est pas tellement marre on fait
je préfère les soirées de priver nager
vous denis brogniart
merci tirs hostiles j'ai une petite
aventure avec lui
[Applaudissements]
en fait j'étais parti à buenos aires
faire l'émission fear factor ouais avec
pas mal de d'animateur de telle sorte de
terminer au pire facteurs mais vous avez
c'est l'épreuve des poteaux comme des
poteaux je suis pas resté longtemps sur
le permis ça oui quand vous avez passé
donc une vie avec denis brogniart et
alors elle va il est roux nehru